The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation, or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: I want to go back to
where I stopped at the end
of Tuesday's lecture, when you
let me pull a fast one on you.
I ended up with a strong
statement that was
effectively a lie.
I told you that when we drop a
large enough number of pins,
and do a large enough number of
trials, we can look at the
small standard deviation we
get across trials and say,
that means we have
a good answer.
It doesn't change much.
And I said, so we can tell you
that with 95% confidence, the
answer lies between x and y,
where we had the two standard
deviations from the mean.
That's not actually true.
I was confusing the notion
of a statistically sound
conclusion with truth.
The utility of every statistical
test rests on
certain assumptions.
So we talked about independence
and things like that.
But the key assumption is that
our simulation is actually a
model of reality.
You can recall that in designing
the simulation, we
looked at the Buffon-Laplace
mathematics and did a little
algebra from which we derived
the code, wrote the code, ran
the simulation, looked at the
results, did the statistical
results, and smiled.
Well, suppose I had made
a coding error.
So, for example, instead of
that 4 there-- which the
algebra said we should have--
I had mistakenly typed a 2.
Not an impossible error.
Now if we run it, what we're
going to see here is that it
converges quite quickly, it
gives me a small standard
deviation, and I can feel very
confident that my answer that
pi is somewhere around 1.569.
Well, it isn't of course.
We know that that's nowhere
close to the value of pi.
But there's nothing wrong
with my statistics.
It's just that my statistics are
about the simulation, not
about pi itself.
So what's the moral here?
Before believing the results of
any simulation, we have to
have confidence that our
conceptual model is correct.
And that we have correctly
implemented
that conceptual model.
How can we do that?
Well, one thing we can
do is test our
results against reality.
So if I ran this and I said pi
is about 1.57, I could go draw
a circle, and I could crudely
measure the circumference, and
I would immediately know
I'm nowhere close
to the right answer.
And that's the right
thing to do.
And in fact, what a scientist
does when they use a
simulation model to derive
something, they always run
some experiments to see whether
their derived result
is actually at least
plausibly correct.
Statistics are good to show
that we've got the little
details right at the end,
but we've got to do a
sanity check first.
So that's a really important
moral to keep in mind.
Don't get seduced by a
statistical test and confuse
that with truth.
All right, I now want to move
on to look at some more
examples that do the same kind
of thing we've been doing.
And in fact, what we're going
to be looking at is the
interplay between physical
reality,--
some physical system, just
in the real world--
some theoretical models of
the physical system, and
computational models.
Because this is really the
way modern science and
engineering is done.
We start with some physical
situation--
and by physical I don't mean
it has to be bricks and
mortar, or physics,
or biology.
The physical situation
could be the stock
market, if you will,--
some real situation
in the world.
We use some theory to give us
some insight into that, and
when the theory gets too
complicated or doesn't get us
all the way to the answer,
we use computation.
And I now want to talk about
how those things relate to
each other.
So imagine, for example, that
you're a bright student in
high school biology, chemistry,
or physics--
a situation probably all of
you who have been in.
You perform some experiment to
the best of your ability.
But you've done the math and
you know your experimental
results don't actually
match the theory.
What should you do?
Well I suspect you've all
been in this situation.
You could just turn in the
results and risk getting
criticized for poor laboratory
technique.
Some of you may have
done this.
More likely what you've done
is you've calculated the
correct results and turned
those in, risking some
suspicion that they're
too good to be true.
But being smart guys, I suspect
what all of you did in
high school is you calculated
the correct results, looked at
your experimental results, and
met somewhere in between to
introduce a little error, but
not look too foolish.
Have any of you cheated that
way in high school?
Yeah well all right.
We have about two people
who would admit it.
The rest of you are either
exceedingly honorable, or just
don't want to admit it.
I confess, I had fudged
experimental
results in high school.
But no longer, I've
seen the truth.
All right, to do this correctly
you need to have a
sense of how best to model not
only reality, but also
experimental errors.
Typically, the best way to model
experimental errors--
and we need to do this
even when we're not
attempting to cheat--
is to assume some sort of random
perturbation of the
actual data.
And in fact, one of the key
steps forward, which was
really Gauss' big contribution,
was to say we
can typically model experimental
error as normally
distributed, as a Gaussian
distribution.
So let's look at an example.
Let's consider a spring.
Not the current time of year, or
a spring of water, but the
kind of spring you looked
at in 8.01.
The things you compress with
some force then they expand,
or you stretch, and then
they contract.
Springs are great things.
We use them in our cars, our
mattresses, seat belts.
We use them to launch
projectiles, lots of things.
And in fact, as we'll see later,
they're frequently
occurring in biology as well.
I don't want to belabor
this, I presume
you've all taken 8.01.
Do they still do springs
in 8.01?
Yes, good, all right.
So as you know, in 1676--
maybe you didn't
know the date--
the British physicist, Robert
Hooke, formulated Hooke's Law
to explain the behavior
of springs.
And the law is very simple,
it's f equals minus kx.
In other words, the force, f,
stored in the spring is
linearly related to x, the
distance the spring has been
either compressed
or stretched.
OK. so that's Hooke's law,
you've all seen that.
The law holds true for a wide
variety of materials and
systems including many
biological systems.
Of course, it does
not hold for an
arbitrarily large force.
All springs have an elastic
limit and if you stretch them
beyond that the law fails.
Has anyone here ever broken
a Slinky that way.
Where you've just taken the
spring and stretched it so
much that it's no
longer useful.
Well you've exceeded
its elastic limit.
The proportionate of constant
here, k, is
called the spring constant.
And every spring has
a constant, k, that
explains its behavior.
If the spring is stiff like
the suspension in an
automobile, k is big.
If the spring is not stiff like
the spring in a ballpoint
pen, k is small.
The negative sign is there to
indicate that the force
exerted by the spring is in the
opposite direction of the
displacement.
If you pull a spring bring down,
the force exerted by the
spring is going up.
Knowing the spring constant of
a spring is actually a matter
of considerable practical
importance.
It's used to do things like
calibrate scales,--
one can use to weigh
oneself, if one
wants to know the truth--
atomic force microscopes,
lots of kinds of things.
And in fact, recently people
have started worrying about
thinking that you should model
DNA as a spring, and finding
the spring constant for
DNA turns out to be of
considerable use in some
biological experiments.
All right, so generations of
students have learned to
estimate springs using this
very simple experiment.
You've probably most of
you have done this.
Get a picture up here,
all right.
So what you do is you take a
spring and you hang it on some
sort of apparatus, and then you
put a weight of known mass
at the bottom of the spring, and
you measure how much the
spring has stretched.
You then can do the math,
if f equals minus kx.
We also have to know that f
equals m times a, mass times
acceleration.
We know that on this planet at
least the acceleration due to
gravity is roughly 9.81 meters
per second per second, and we
can just do the algebra and
we can calculate k.
So we hang one weight in the
spring, we measure it, we say,
we're done.
We now know what k is
for that spring.
Not so easy, of course, to do
this experiment if the spring
is a strand of DNA.
So you need a slightly
more complicated
apparatus to do that.
This would be all well and
good if we didn't have
experimental error, but we do.
Any experiment we typically
have errors.
So what people do instead is
rather than hanging one weight
on the spring, they hang
different weights--
weights of different mass--
they wait for the spring to stop
moving and they measure
it, and now they have
a series of points.
And they assume that, well I've
got some errors and if we
believe that our errors are
normally distributed some will
be positive, some will
be negative.
And if we do enough experiments
it will kind of
all balance out and we'll be
able to actually get a good
estimate of the spring
constant, k.
I did such an experiment, put
the results in a file.
This is just a format
of the file.
The first line tells us what
it is, it's the distance in
meters and a mass
in kilograms.
And then I just have the two
things separated by a space,
in this case.
So my first experiment, the
distance I measured was 0.0865
and the weight was
0.1 kilograms.
All right, so I've now got
the data, so that's
the physical reality.
I've done my experiment.
I've done some theory telling
me how to calculate k.
And now I'm going to put them
together and write some code.
So let's look at the code.
Think we'll skip over this, and
I'll comment this out, so
we don't see get pi get
estimated over and over again.
So the first piece of code is
pretty simple, it's just
getting the data.
And again, this is typically the
way one ought to structure
these things.
I/O, input/output, is typically
done in a separate
function so that if the format
of the data were changed, I'd
only have to change this,
and not the rest of my
computation.
it opens the file, discards the
header, and then uses a
split to get the x values and
the y values, all right.
So now I just get all the
distances and all the masses--
not the x's and the y's yet,
just distances and masses.
Then I close the file
and return them.
Nothing that you haven't
seen before.
Nothing that you won't get to
write again, and again, and
again, similar kinds
of things.
Then I plot the data.
So here we see something that's
a little bit different
from what we've seen before.
So the first thing I do
is I got my x and
y by calling, GetData.
Then I do a type conversion.
What GetData is returning
is a list.
I'm here going to convert
a list to another
type called an array.
This is a type implemented by
a class supplied by PyLab
which is built on top of
something called NumPy, which
is where it comes from.
An array is kind
of like a list.
It's a sequence of things.
There's some list operations
methods that are not
available, like append, but
it's got some other things
that are extremely valuable.
For example, I can
do point-wise
operations on an array.
So if I multiply an array by
3, what that does is it
multiplies each element by 3.
If I multiply one array
by another, it
does the cross products.
OK, so they're very valuable
for these kinds of things.
Typically, in Python, one starts
with a list, because
lists are more convenient to
build up incrementally than
arrays, and then converts them
to an array so that you can do
the math on them.
For those of you who've seen
MATLAB you're very familiar
with the concept of what
Python calls an array.
Those of you who know C or
Pascal, what it calls an array
has nothing to do with
what Python or
PyLab calls an array.
So can be a little
bit confusing.
Any rate, I convert
them to arrays.
And then what I'll do here, now
that I have an array, I'll
multiply my x values by the
acceleration due to gravity,
this constant 9.81.
And then I'm just going
to plot them.
All right, so let's see
what we get here.
So here I've now plotted
the measure
displacement of the spring.
Force in Newtons, that's the
standard international unit
for measuring force.
It's the amount of force needed
to accelerate a mass of
1 kilogram at a rate of 1 meter
per second per second.
So I've plotted the force
in Newton's against
the distance in meters.
OK.
Now I can go and calculate k.
Well, how am I going
to do that?
Well, before I do that, I'm
going to do something to see
whether or not my data
is sensible.
What we often do, is we have
a theoretical model and the
model here is that the data
should fall on a line, roughly
speaking, modular experimental
errors.
I'm going to now find out
what that line is.
Because if I know that line,
I can compute k.
How does k relate
to that line?
So I plot a line.
And now I can look at the
slope of that line, how
quickly it's changing.
And k will be simply the
inverse of that.
How do I get the line?
Well, I'm going to find a line
that is the best approximation
to the points I have.
So if, for example, I have two
points, a point here and a
point here, I know I
can quote, fit a
line to that curve--
to those points--
it will always be perfect.
It will be a line.
So this is what's
called a fit.
Now if I have a bunch of points
sort of scattered
around, I then have to figure
out, OK, what line is the
closest to those points?
What fits it the best?
And I might say, OK, it's
a line like this.
But in order to do that, in
order to fit a line to more
than two points, I need
some measure of the
goodness of the fit.
Because what I want to choose
here is the best fit.
What line is the best
approximation of the data I've
actually got?
But in order to do that, I need
some objective function
that tells me how good
is a particular fit.
It lets me compare two
fits so that I can
choose the best one.
OK, now if we want to look at
that we have to ask, what
should that be?
There are lots of
possibilities.
One could say, all right let's
find the line that goes
through the most points,
that actually
touches the most points.
The problem with that is it's
really hard, and may be
totally irrelevant, and in fact
you may not find a line
that touches more
than one point.
So we need something
different.
And there is a standard measure
that's typically used
and that's called the
least squares fit.
That's the objective function
that's almost always used in
measuring how good any curve--
or how well, excuse me, any
curve fits a set of points.
What it looks like is the sum
from L equals 0 to L equals
the len of the observed points
minus 1, just because of the
way things will work
in Python.
But the key thing is what we're
summing is the observed
at point L minus the predicted
at point L-squared.
And since we're looking for the
least squares fit, we want
to minimize that.
The smallest difference
we can get.
So there's some things
to notice about this.
Once we have a quote fit, in
this case a line for every x
value the fit predicts
a y value.
Right?
That's what our model does.
Our model in this case will take
the independent variable,
x, the mass, and predict the
dependent variable, the
displacement.
But in addition to the predicted
values, we have the
observed values, these guys.
And now we just measure the
difference between the
predicted and the observed,
square it, and notice by
squaring the difference we have
discarded whether it's
above or below the line--
because we don't care, we just
care how far it's
from the line.
And then we sum all of those up
and the smaller we can make
that, the better our fit is.
Makes sense?
So now how do we find
the best fit?
Well, there's several different
methods you could use.
You can actually do this
using Newton's method.
Under many conditions there are
analytical solutions, so
you don't have to use
approximation you can just
compute it.
And the best news of all, it's
built into PyLab So that's how
you actually do it.
You call the PyLab function
that does it for you.
That function is
called Polyfit.
Polyfit takes three arguments.
It takes all of the observed X
values, all of the observed Y
values, and the degree
of the polynomial.
So I've been talking about
fitting lines.
As we'll see, polyfit can be
used to fit polynomials of
arbitrary degree to data.
So you can fit a line,
you can fit a
parabola, you can fit cubic.
I don't know what it's called,
you can fit a 10th order
polynomial, whatever
you choose here.
And then it returns
some values.
So if we think about it being
a line, we know that it's
defined by the y value is
equal to ax plus b.
Some constant times the x value
plus b, the y-intercept.
So now let's look at it.
We see here in fit data, what
I've done is I've gotten my
values as before, and now I'm
going to say, a,b equals
pyLab.polyfit of xVals,
y values and 1.
Since I'm looking for a
line, the degree is 1.
Once I've got that, I can then
compute the estimated y
values, a times pyLab.array.
I'm turning the x values into
an array, actually I didn't
need to do that since I'd
already done it, that's okay--
plus b.
And now I'll plot it and, by the
way now that I've got my
line, I can also compute k.
And let's see what we get.
All right, I fit a line, and
I've got a linear fit, and I
said my spring constant
k is 21 point --
I've rounded it to 5 digits
just so would fit
nicely on my plot.
OK.
The method that's used to do
this in PyLab is called a
linear regression.
Now you might think it's called
linear regression
because I just used it to find a
line, but in fact that's not
why it's called linear
regression.
Because we can use linear
regression to find a parabola,
or a cubic, or anything else.
The reason it's called linear,
well let's look at an example.
So if I wanted a parabola, I
would have y equals ax-squared
plus bx plus c.
We think of the variables, the
independent variables, as
x-squared and x.
And y is indeed a linear
function of those variables,
because we're adding terms.
Not important that you
understand the details, it is
important that you know that
linear regression can be used
to find polynomials
other than lines.
All right, so we
got this done.
Should we be happy?
We can look at this, we fit
the best line to this data
point, we computed
k, are we done?
Well I'm kind of concerned,
because when I look at my
picture it is the best line I
can fit to this, but wow it's
not a very good fit in
some sense, right.
I look at that line, the
points are pretty
far away from it.
And if it's not a good fit, then
I have to be suspicious
about my value of k, which is
derived from having the model
I get by doing this fit.
Well, all right, let's
try something else.
Let's look at FitData1, which in
addition to doing a linear
fit, I'm going to
fit a cubic --
partly to show you
how to do it.
Here I'm going to say abcd
equals pyLab.polyfit of xVals,
yVals and 3 instead of 1.
So it's a more complex
function.
Let's see what that gives us.
First let me comment that out.
So we're going to now compare
visually what we get when we
get a line fit versus we get a
cubic fit to the same data.
Well it looks to me like a
cubic is a much better
description of the data, a much
better model of the data,
than a line.
Pretty good.
Well, should I be
happy with this?
Well, let's ask ourselves in
one question, why are we
building the model?
We're building the model so that
we can better understand
the spring.
One of the things we often do
with models is use them to
predict values that we have not
been able to run in our
experiments.
So, for example, if you're
building a model of a nuclear
reactor you might want to know
what happens when the power is
turned off for some
period of time.
In fact, if you read today's
paper you noticed they've just
done a simulation model of a
nuclear reactor, in, I think,
Tennessee, and discovered that
if it lost power for more than
two days, it would start
to look like the
nuclear reactors in Japan.
Not a very good thing.
But of course, that's
not an experiment
anyone wants to run.
No one wants to blow up this
nuclear reactor just to see
what happens.
So they do use a simulation
model to predict what would
happen in an experiment
you can't run.
So let's use our model here
to do some predictions.
So here I've taken the same
program, I've called it
FitData2, but what I've done
is I've added a point.
So instead of just looking at
the x values, I'm looking at
something I'm calling extended
x, where I've added a weight
of 1 and a 1/2 kilos to the
spring just to see what would
happen, what the model
would predict.
And other than that, everything
is the same.
Oops, what's happened here?
Probably shouldn't be computing
k here with a
non-linear model.
All right, why is it not?
Come on, there it is.
And now we have to un-comment
this out, un-comment this.
Well it fit the existing data
pretty darn well, but it has a
very strange prediction here.
If you think about our
experiment, it's predicting
not only that the spring stopped
stretching, but that
it goes to above where
it started.
Highly unlikely in
a physical world.
So what we see here is that
while I can easily fit a curve
to the data, it fits it
beautifully, it turns out to
have very bad predictive
value.
What's going on here?
Well, I started this whole
endeavor under an assumption
that there was some theory about
springs, Hooke's law,
and that it should be
a linear model.
Just because my data maybe
didn't fit that theory,
doesn't mean I should just fit
an arbitrary curve and see
what happens.
It is the case that if you're
willing to get a high enough
degree polynomial, you can
get a pretty good fit
to almost any data.
But that doesn't
prove anything.
It's not useful.
It's one of the reasons why when
I read papers I always
like to see the raw data.
I hate it when I read a
technical paper and it just
shows me the curve that they fit
to the data, rather than
the data, because it's easy to
get to the wrong place here.
So let's for the moment
ignore the curves and
look at the raw data.
What do we see here about
the raw data?
Well, it looks like at the
end it's flattening out.
Well, that violates Hooke's law,
which says I should have
a linear relationship.
Suddenly it stopped
being linear.
Have we violated Hooke's law?
Have I done something so strange
that maybe I should
just give up on this
experiment?
What's the deal here?
So, does this data contradict
Hooke's law?
Let me ask that question.
Yes or no?
Who says no?
AUDIENCE: Hooke's law applies
only for small displacements.
PROFESSOR: Well, not
necessarily small.
But only up to an
elastic limit.
AUDIENCE: Which is in the scheme
of inifinitely small.
PROFESSOR: Compared to
infinity [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Yes, sorry, up to the
limit where the linearity
breaks down.
PROFESSOR: Exactly right.
Oh, I overthrew my hand here.
AUDIENCE: I'll get it.
PROFESSOR: Pick it up
on your way out.
Exactly, it doesn't.
It just says, probably I
exceeded the elastic limit of
my spring in this experiment.
Well now, let's go back and
let's go back to our original
code and see what happens if I
discard the last six points,
where it's flattened out.
The points that seem to be where
I've exceeded the limit.
So I can easily do that.
Do this little coding hack.
It's so much easier to do
experiments with code than
with physical objects.
Now let's see what we get.
Well, we get something that's
visually a much better fit.
And we get a very different
value of k.
So we're a lot happier here.
And if I fit cubic to this you
would find that the cubic and
the line actually look
a lot alike.
So this is a good
thing, I guess.
On the other hand, how do we
know which line is a better
representation of physical
reality, a better model.
After all, I could delete all
the points except any two and
then I would get a line that was
a perfect fit, R-squared
-- you know the mean squared
error -- would be 0, right?
Because you can fit a line
to any two points.
So again, we're seeing that we
have a question here that
can't be answered
by statistics.
It's not just a question
of how good my fit is.
I have to go back
to the theory.
And what my theory tells me is
that it should be linear, and
I have a theoretical
justification of discarding
those last six points.
It's plausible that I
exceeded the limit.
I don't have a theoretical
justification of deleting six
arbitrary points somewhere in
the middle that I didn't
happen to like because they
didn't fit the data.
So again, the theme that I'm
getting to is this interplay
between physical reality,--
in this case the experiment--
the theoretical model,-- in
this case Hooke's law--
and my computational model,
-- the line I fit to the
experimental data.
OK, let's continue down this
path and I want to look at
another experiment, also with
a spring but this is a
different spring.
Maybe I'll bring in that spring
in the next lecture and
show it to you.
This spring is a
bow and arrow.
Actually the bow
is the spring.
Anyone here ever shot
a bow and arrow?
Well what you know is the
bow has the limbs in it.
And when you pull back the
string, you are putting force
in the limbs, which are
essentially a spring.
And when you release the spring
goes back to the place
it wants to be and fires the
projectile on some trajectory.
I now am interested in looking
at the trajectory followed by
such a projectile.
This, by the way, is where a
lot of this math came from.
People were looking at
projectiles, not typically of
bows, but of artillery shells,
where the force there was the
force of some chemical
reaction.
OK, so once again I've
got some data.
In a file, similar
kind of format.
And I'm going to read that
data in and plot it.
So let's do that.
So I'm going to get my
trajectory data.
The way I did this, by the way,
is I actually did this
experiment.
I fired four arrows from
different distances and
measured the mean height
of the four.
So I'm getting at heights
1, 2, 3, and 4.
Again, don't worry about this.
And then I'm going
to try some fits.
And let's see what
we get here.
So I got my data inches from
launch point, and inches above
launch point.
And then I fit a line to it.
And you can see there's a little
point way down here in
the corner.
The launch point and the target
were at actually the
same height for this
experiment.
And not surprisingly, the bow
was angled up, I guess, the
arrow went up, and then
it came down, and
ended up in the target.
I fit a line to it.
That's the best line I can
fit to these points.
Well, it's not real good.
So let's pretend I didn't know
anything about projectiles.
I can now use computation to try
and understand the theory.
Assume I didn't know
the theory.
And what the theory tells me
here, or what the computation
tells me, the theory that the
arrow travels in a straight
line is not a very good one.
All right, this does not
actually conform at all to the
data, I probably should reject
this theory that says the
arrow goes straight.
If you looked at the arrows,
by the way, in a short
distance it would kind of look
to your eyes like it was
actually going straight.
But in fact, physics tells us
it can't and the model tells
us it didn't.
All right let's try
a different one.
Let's compare the linear
fit to a quadratic fit.
So now I'm using polyfit
with a degree of 2.
See what we get here.
Well our eyes tell us it's not
a perfect fit, but it's a lot
better fit, right.
So this is suggesting that maybe
the arrow is traveling
in a parabola, rather than
a straight line.
The next question is, our eyes
tell us it's better.
How much better?
How do we go about measuring
which fit is better?
Recall that we started by saying
what polyfit is doing
is minimizing the mean
square error.
So one way to compare two fits
would be to say what's the
mean square error of the line?
What's the mean square error
of the parabola?
Well, pretty clear
it's going to be
smaller for the parabola.
So that would tell us OK
it is a better fit.
And in fact computing the mean
square error is a good way to
compare the fit of two
different curves.
On the other hand, it's not
particularly useful for
telling us the goodness of the
fit in absolute terms.
So I can tell you that the
parabola is better than the
line, but in some sense mean
square error can't be used to
tell me how good it is
in an absolute sense.
Why is that so?
It's because mean
square error --
there's a lower bound 0, but
there's no upper bound.
It can go arbitrarily high.
And that is not so good for
something where we're trying
to measure things.
So instead, what we typically
use is something called the
coefficient of determination.
Usually written, for
reasons you'll see
shortly, as r squared.
So the coefficient of
determination, R-squared, is
equal to 1 minus the estimated
error EE over MV, which is the
variance in the measured data.
So we're comparing the ratio
of the estimated error, our
best estimate of the error,
and a measurement of how
variable the data is
to start with.
As we'll see, this value is
always less than 1, less than
or equal to 1, and therefore
R-squared is always going to
be between 0 and 1.
Which gives us a nice way of
thinking about it in an
absolute sense.
All right, so where
are these values?
How do we compute them?
Well, I'm going to explain it
the easiest way I know, which
is by showing you the code.
So I have the measured values
and the estimated values.
The estimated error
is going to be--
I take estimated value, the
value given me by the model,
subtract the measured value,
and square it and
then I just sum them.
All right, this is like what
we looked at for the mean
square error, but I'm not
computing the mean, right.
I'm getting the total of
the estimated errors.
I can then get the measured
mean, which is the measured
sum, divided by the length
of the measurement.
That gives me the mean
of the measured data.
And then my measured variance is
going to be the mean of the
measured data minus each point
of the measured data squared,
and then summing that.
So just as we looked at before
when we looked at the
coefficient of variation, and
standard deviation, by
comparing how far things stray
from the mean, that tells us
how much variance there
is in the data.
And then I'll return
1 minus that.
OK, Tuesday we'll go look
at this in more detail.
Thank you.